three major retailers now plan to phase
out paint stripping products containing
a potentially deadly chemical health
authorities believe strippers with toxic
methylene chloride have claimed dozens
of lives after a CBS News investigation
Home Depot Sherwin Williams and Lowe's
all say they're gonna stop selling those
products by the end of the year
Anna Warner has investigated this story
for months Anna you had that story here
first it looks like things are changing
good morning things definitely are
changing it's very interesting now EPA
scientists as we've told you have said
that this chemical poses an unreasonable
risk but products containing methylene
chloride have been sold to consumers for
years we've told you how victims usually
young men have died after doing things
like stripping paint off a car for
example those families have been pushing
for action not only at the EPA but at
the retail level we reached out to those
three companies planning to stop the
sale of these products now by the end of
the year Lowe's says it wants to bring
safer affordable options to customers
Home Depot also says it wants to improve
health and environmental safety for
products and sherwin-williams says it
also has effective alternatives that do
not contain methylene chloride there was
a lot of concern that the EPA would not
uphold its planned ban on this chemical
activists now say they are cautiously
optimistic to the idea that that will
happen but that's going to take much
longer and in the meantime families say
they are not willing to wait and watch
more people die these deaths can happen
really quick remind us the story you've
told of people who have died using so
typically what happens is you know you
go to a store and you buy a can of paint
stripper you're gonna strip paint off a
car or off furniture or something like
that if you use it indoors your life can
be at risk in an enclosed space because
you really need so much more ventilation
than in a normal situation you actually
need and some enclosed spaces you need a
piece of equipment that forces oxygen
into your face with a tube running out
this way well consumers don't have that
and people are unaware of the danger
because you could buy it off the shelf a
lot of people don't read labels
you know these labels can be confused
and I think they're certainly paying
attention now thank you Anna thank you
very much